le 2 décembre dernier que le Président
de la République envisageait de vous
nommer aux fonctions de président du
conseil d'administration de l'Agence de
financement des infrastructures de
transport
de France Lafitte comme vous le savez
cette nomination ne peut intervenir
qu'après l'audition de la personne
pressenti devant les commissions
compétentes à la fois de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat audition qui
seront suivies d'un vote cette audition
est publique elle est ouverte à la
presse à son issus nous procéderons à un
vote pour lequel il ne peut y avoir de
délégation de vote la commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire à
l'Assemblée nationale vous entendrez
également son tour aujourd'hui à 11h30
et c'est à l'issue de cette deuxième
édition que nous procéderons
dépouillement simultané de ce scrutin
avec celui de l'Assemblée nationale
je vous rappelle que en application de
l'article 13 de la Constitution il ne
pourrait être procédé à cette nomination
si l'addition des votes négatifs de
chaque commission représentée au moins
3/5 des suffrages exprimés dans les deux
commissions votre audition intervient un
moment charnière pour la fitte et cela a
double titre d'une part la gouvernance
de l'agence à laquelle notre commission
est très attentive a connu d'importants
bouleversements en juillet 2022
Christophe vécut alors président de son
conseil d'administration a été nommé
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires un mois
plus tard et avec la valve de notre
commission et celle de l'Assemblée
nationale Jean Castex candidat proposé
par le Président de la République a été
désigné pour lui succéder moins de trois
mois plus tard un décret mettait fin à
ses fonctions à Lafitte afin de lui
permettre d'exercer les fonctions de
président directeur général de la RATP
votre candidature intervient donc à
l'issue de ces rebondissements et nous
ne pouvons que souhaiter à la fit de
disposer pour les années à venir du
nécessaire stabilité
d'autre part nous sommes à la veille de
la remise du rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures
rapports qui est extrêmement attendu et
qui devrait a priori servir de support
au futur arbitrages du gouvernement
arbitrage en matière de financement des
infrastructures de transport de fait il
est probable que la feuille de route de
Lafitte évolue dans les prochains mois
et années en lien avec les décisions
politiques du gouvernement et du
législateur je rappelle que la fit est
un établissement public national à
caractère administratif placé sous la
tutelle du ministre chargé des
transports et que sa mission est de
concourir au financement des projets
relatifs à la réalisation ou à
l'aménagement d'infrastructures qu'elles
soient routière ferroviaire fluviale et
portuaire mais aussi de projets relatifs
à la création et au développement de
transport collectif de la personne
le rôle de la fuite sera donc de fait
particulièrement utile pour atteindre
l'objectif de décarbonation du secteur
des transports à l'horizon 2050 je vais
à présent laisser la parole à notre
rapporteur Bruno Belin qui va conduire
votre audition vous pouvez ensuite nous
présenter votre candidature et nous part
de vos motivations avant de répondre aux
premières questions du rapporteur à
l'issue de cet échange mes collègues
vous interrogerons à leur tour pour une
séquence de questions-réponses je vous
remercie la parole est en rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues bonjour Monsieur le Maire nous
sommes ravis de vous entendre
aujourd'hui comme la souligner le
président et compte tenu du rôle central
de la fuite pour le secteur des
transports nous ne pouvons que souhaiter
davantage de stabilité et de visibilité
à l'agence afin de lui permettre
d'assurer ses missions dans les
meilleures conditions il s'agit donc
aujourd'hui pour nous de déterminer si
vous êtes le candidat idéal pour prendre
la tête de son conseil d'administration
c'est pourquoi je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur trois principaux sujets
la programmation des dépenses de
l'agence sa trajectoire de recettes est
plus globalement votre vision
prospective du rôle de la fit
s'agit si Jean des dépenses de la fuite
nous entrons dans une séquence clé pour
l'agence comme l'indiqué le Président le
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures devraient remettre
prochainement son rapport pour préparer
la révision de la programmation des
infrastructures de transport prévues par
la loi d'orientation des mobilités
qui dans son article 2 dit que les
dépenses prévues pour la période 2023
2027 s'élève à 14,3 milliards d'euros
contre 13,7 pour la période 2019-2023
hors depuis la définition de cette
trajectoire en 2019 de nouveaux
engagements ont été actés notamment en
faveur du chantier Lyon-Turin du canal
senor Europe de fait nous serons amenés
à réviser la nouvelle trajectoire de
dépenses de la fuite afin de la mettre
en cohérence avec les objectifs et d'en
préciser le niveau annuel à la lumière
des travaux du comité d'orientation des
infrastructures
par ailleurs le volet molobilité des
contrats de plan est à région pour 2023
2027 est en cours de finalisation
d'après vous comment l'agence doit-elle
envisager ces échéances de court terme
pensez-vous que la fuite puisse faire
face au mur d'investissement de 200
milliards d'euros sur les 10 prochaines
années identifiées par le comité
d'orientation des infrastructures par
ailleurs dans quelle mesure estimez-vous
que l'affite doit contribuer au
déploiement des RER métropolitain
en toute en outre pardon toujours en
matière de dépenses les récents avis
budgétaires de nos éminents collectent à
barreaux gilet ont mis en lumière un
problème de sous-consommation
et crédit de la fit notamment en rapport
de certains chantiers
d'après vous la fuite est-elle en
capacité d'assurer le déploiement et
l'exécution d'une nouvelle trajectoire
plus ambitieuse et d'affiner les
évaluations des dépenses des projets
d'infrastructure et le suivi des
chantiers qu'elle finance
à cet égard vous prédécesseurs avaient
souligné les moyens humains limités dont
dispose la fuite avec seulement 4
équivalentes en plein pour un budget
annuel qui frôle les 4 milliards d'euros
en 2023
c'est qu'il y a cette question
sera-t-elle au cœur de vos
préoccupations
en outre le mouvement dit des gilets
jaunes récemment réduit le produit des
amendes radar dont l'agence figure aux
derniers rang des priorités des
bénéficiaires
la crise sanitaire a par ailleurs privée
jusqu'en 2002 pardon la fille de la
contribution du secteur aérien
enfin la société concessionnaire
d'autoroute refuse depuis 2021 de
s'acquitter du versement de la
contribution volontaire exceptionnelle à
la fuite
dans ce contexte la TICPE
présente à ce jour la recette la plus
stable de la fuite alors même que ces
perspectives sont à long terme plutôt
négatives étant donné l'objectif de
décarbonation du secteur des transports
aussi notre commission appelle de ses
vœux depuis plusieurs années à sécuriser
le modèle de financement de la fit
avez-vous
identifié des propositions en la matière
par exemple en s'inspirant d'autres
modèles européens
par ailleurs votre prédécesseur Jean
Castex avait avancé l'idée devant notre
commission de trouver de nouvelles
recettes affectées qu'il avait qualifié
de nouveaux paniers de recettes que
pensez-vous de cette suggestion
je souhaiterais également vous
interroger de manière plus prospective
sur votre vision du rôle de l'agence
comme vous le savez la Cour des comptes
avait dans son référé 2016 émis de
fortes réserves sur le fonctionnement de
la fuite l'assimilant une simple caisse
de financement
servant principalement à contourner les
principes du trois budgétaire
si la Cour a plus récemment pris acte
d'avancer positive elle estime que le
conseil municipration de l'agence doit
assurer pleinement ses responsabilités
en hiérarchisant les projets et en
garantissant leur conformité à la
trajectoire financière
cette problématique pose de fait la
question de la liberté donnée à la fuite
pour se prononcer sur la pertinence des
projets financés
d'après vous le rôle de la fit a-t-il
vocation à évoluer pour sortir de cette
stricte logique de caisse de financement
enfin je vous souhaiterais vous entendre
sur la façon dont vous envisagez de
cumuler votre fonction de merde
Dunkerque et de président de la
Communauté urbaine avec celle si nous le
votion évidemment de président du
conseil de la fuite Christophe Béchu
avait fait le choix de conserver son
mandat de mer danger tout en assurant
c'est même fonction comment
envisagez-vous de concilier vos
fonctions de mer et de président de la
communauté d'agglo de comité d'urbaine
pardon avec la présence du conseil
d'administration je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
rapporteur Monsieur le Maire c'est de la
parole
bonjour monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis un peu ému c'est la
première fois que je me retrouve comme
ça devant une commission du Sénat c'est
quand même impressionnant en tout cas je
suis honoré devant vous aujourd'hui et
honoré par la proposition du Président
de la République de cette proposition de
nomination à la présidence de Lafitte et
se réserve bien entendu de votre accord
et je veux aussi j'en profite pour
saluer le travail qui a été mené par
Christophe Béchu Jean Castex également
qui se déchu donc qui est devenu l'un
des ministres de tutelle de la fille de
vous l'avez dit et je veux également
saluer Clément bonne l'autre ministre de
tutelle ils ont été aussi pour quelque
chose dans la confiance aujourd'hui qui
m'est donné que j'espère que vous allez
pouvoir valider
j'avoue que j'ai été ravi quand cette
proposition m'a été faite d'abord
peut-être à titre personnel parce que je
dois avouer que dans ma vie qu'elle soit
professionnelle ou politique c'est
toujours été passionné par la question
d'aménagement du territoire les
questions de fabrique urbaine ça m'a
suivi je regarde tout au long de tout au
long de ma vie et évidemment la question
des mobilités a toujours été centrale
dans ces questions là aménagement du
territoire fabric urbaine des questions
de mobilité sont vraiment au centre donc
quelque part ça ça rejoignait des sujets
et un sujet qui qui m'est
particulièrement cher et ensuite
évidemment
deuxième élément qui qui m'a beaucoup
motivé c'est et vous l'avez dit quelque
part sur le président monsieur le
rapporteur vous l'avez dit dans votre
propos introductif
aujourd'hui les mobilités c'est un enjeu
clé pour l'avenir de notre pays vous
avez évoqué la question de la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique qui
induit une décarbonation des mobilités
on aurait pu évoquer les questions
d'aménagement du territoire et
aujourd'hui la façon dont notre pays
aborde la question de en métropolisation
et la question de l'équilibre
territoriale et l'échelle nationale on
aurait pu parler des difficultés
rencontrent nos concitoyens au quotidien
face à la montée des prises des prix de
l'énergie notamment du carburant mais
aussi face à un service ferroviaire
aujourd'hui qui est devenu difficile et
parfois défaillant on aurait pu évoquer
l'impact des mobilités sur la croissance
économique pour évoquer les questions de
nuisances liées au bruit les questions
de coupure urbaines à passer aussi dans
la politique de la ville qui m'a fait
prendre conscience de l'importance
justement de la question des
infrastructures dans dans l'isolement
d'un certain nombre de quartiers de la
politique de la ville donc on aurait pu
évoquer ces questions là on aurait pu
évoquer la sécurité des ouvrages d'art
on aurait pu évoquer la question de la
résilience de nos infrastructures par
rapport au changement climatique et
notamment au réchauffement donc
ces enjeux sont immenses et donc pouvoir
y apporter ma pierre en tant qu'élu
locale du territoire dunkerquois au cœur
finalement des réseaux d'infrastructures
européens dans une agglomération qui a
voulu faire aussi de la mobilité une de
ses priorités pour moi c'était aussi une
motivation forte donc à la fois
motivation personnelle à la fois
motivation par les enjeux donc j'avoue
que j'ai été particulièrement ravi de
pouvoir apprendre cette proposition la
fuite pour moi est un bon outil
justement pour aborder cette question
des mobilités dans l'avenir
pour trois pour trois points j'ai envie
de dire pour trois raisons d'abord parce
que je pense que c'est malgré tout une
forme de garantie du temps long
et ses recettes affectées même si elles
plaisent pas toujours à Bercy me semble
utile quand on parle de développement
des infrastructures elle permet aussi
une lisibilité des projets structurants
peut-être plus que ce qui pourrait être
fait avec le programme de 103 et puis
aussi parce que elle est un outil
partenariat je vais d'ailleurs remercier
les parlementaires qui siègent au
conseil d'administration de Lafitte il y
a également des élus locaux
peut-être d'ailleurs que cette dimension
partenariale dans les années qui
viennent mériterait d'être renforcé
parce que je pense que essayer
d'associer et les parlementaires et les
élus locaux davantage aux réflexions
liées à la fuite peut être à mon avis
qu'une source de
d'intérêt pour pour la fuite et
justement pour pour le pour les choix
qui pourrait être fait en termes de
développement des infrastructures vous
posiez la question sur le rôle que je
perçois de la fille je ne suis pas
encore Président je regarde ça de très
loin
si je devais l'associer à quelque chose
qui m'est familier en tant qu'il est
local je dirais finalement la fille de
joue un peu le rôle de conseil de
surveillance plus qu'à en réalité un
conseil d'administration
cette capacité à rajouter des yeux sur
des choix et des arbitrages qui peuvent
être faits en matière de développement
des infrastructures et c'est peut-être
un petit peu comme ça que j'imagine le
conseil d'administration de la fille
peut-être plus comme un conseil de
surveillance en réalité conseil de
surveillance du siège au Grand Port
Maritime de Dunkerque à l'hôpital bien
évidemment et je trouve que le rôle du
conseil d'administration de la filtre
ressemble peut-être plus à ce type
d'instance qu'à un véritable conseil
d'administration voilà un petit peu
comment comment j'imagine comment
j'imagine les choses en tout cas cette
dimension de facilité le partenariat
faciliter le dialogue entre toutes les
parties prenantes dans un sujet les
infrastructures qui mobilisent
finalement beaucoup d'acteurs me semble
pertinents
alors pour ça ça suppose évidemment
d'approfondir les axes prioritaires qui
ont été définis par Christophe Béchu
hébergeon Castex à la fois sur labilité
financière essayer de faciliter la
transition écologique assurer aussi
l'efficacité la transparence de de la
fuite
pour moi d'abord en garantissant les
orientations fixées dans la lame ça me
semble être la garantie de la fuite en
veillant effectivement et vous l'avez
dit à des ressources pérennées stables
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion pour
cette édition de revenir forcément sur
ce que vous avez évoqué sur les dépenses
et les recettes et puis tous les deux
fournir tous les éléments nécessaires à
la représentation nationale justement
pour qu'elle puisse pour qu'elle puisse
justement apprécier le travail de la
fuite et on exprimait des orientations
aussi
vous l'avez dit
2023 ça va être une année très
importante pas simplement pour la fuite
en réalité mais pour notre pays et la
stratégie de des mobilités dans ce pays
en réalité donc quelques jours le CUI va
donc rendre son rapport et ce sera le
début d'une séquence d'intense réflexion
de débats autour de l'ambition que donne
ce pays à la mobilité mais aux grandes
infrastructures
[Musique]
je pense que mon rôle sera d'essayer de
faciliter de le dialogue le débat tout
ce qui pourra permettre effectivement de
d'échanger et d'arriver à théoriquement
ce qui doit être une actualisation de
l'homme
les volets mobilités du CPE er et aussi
je ne l'oublie pas un contrat
d'orientation d'objectif pardon et de
performance pour lafit qui doit répondre
à la question des moyens humains que
vous évoquiez et je pense que c'est
plutôt bien et sain que soit lié à peu
près dans le même calendrier
actualisation de la Lomme volet mobilité
des CPER et contrats d'objectifs et de
performance de la fuite parce qu'une
fois effectivement ces éléments fait je
pense qu'on aura effectivement on pourra
adapter aussi les moyens humains de
l'agence et le fonctionnement de
l'agence à l'ambition que je donne ce
pays finalement pour les pour les années
qui viennent
il y a déjà un marqueur dans ce budget
2023 de lafit
c'est le budget historiquement le plus
haut 4,2 milliards en
autorisation d'engagement
il y a eu un ajout effectivement de 150
millions de d'euros au niveau du au
moment du PLF je pense qu'il y a déjà
des marqueurs pour prendre en compte ce
que vous avez dit c'est-à-dire les
besoins immenses qui qui sont devant
nous pour les années qui viennent
je ne connais pas encore le rapport du
coi mais il y a une chose dont je suis
certain comme vous c'est et vous l'avez
dit quand vous avez évoqué cette
question du mur d'investissement qui a
été évoquée d'ailleurs dans le rapport
du coi c'est que
les moyens seront seront nécessairement
à la hausse les besoins en tout cas sont
à la hausse et les moyens devront être
identifiés à la hausse
donc je pense que la réflexion qui va
s'ouvrir dans les six mois qui viennent
sera une réflexion sur
jusqu'à quel niveau on se donne on se
donne collectivement se donne le pays en
termes d'ambition pour le développement
des infrastructures donc quelles est le
niveau de dépense acceptable et
pertinent et comment on arrive à trouver
les recettes qui correspondent et dans
ma tête je
j'imagine très probablement que ce sera
effectivement à la hausse tant les
besoins sont importants
alors certains parlent de mieux en
investissements j'ai entendu aussi
l'expression de plan Marshall pour les
infrastructures en particulier pour le
rail je pense que toutes ces expressions
aujourd'hui ont du sens et correspondent
à une réalité donc je pense que le débat
qui s'ouvre finalement dans les six mois
c'est d'un débat à la fois sur le niveau
de dépenses acceptable mais
nécessairement à la hausse selon moi et
donc les moyens de trouver les recettes
qui correspondent à ces dépenses là
je
terminerai ce propos introductif sur sur
mon positionnement et puis vous l'avez
évoqué à la fin quand on parliez du
cumul
moi je
[Musique]
j'imagine le rôle du président de
Lafitte davantage comme
facilitateur du dialogue de l'échange
à la fois avec la représentation
nationale que vous êtes et à la fois
aussi avec les élus locaux
je pense que il est important que le
président de la fille joue ce rôle
justement de d'aller-retour entre d'un
côté l'explication de choix qui peuvent
être opérés à l'échelle nationale parce
qu'on ne peut pas tout financer voilà
dans n'importe quel cadre mais aussi la
remontée des injonctions contradictoires
qu'on a parfois sur le terrain que voilà
et moi je pense que cette question du
cumul est plutôt un avantage la fuite
c'est une toute petite structure trop
petite d'ailleurs on l'a dit tout à
l'heure c'est 5 personnes
Catherine bosbrugger qui est juste
derrière moi je j'ai envie de dire si je
n'étais pas enfin si j'étais à temps
plein président de la fille je pense que
je lui marcherai sur les pieds au
quotidien et je pense que ce n'est pas
le rôle d'un président de la fille que
de s'impliquer dans le management d'une
structure de cinq personnes il y a une
secrétaire général et elle fait très
bien son travail aujourd'hui la question
des moyens peut évoluer mais de toute
façon ce sera jamais une agence avec un
effectif pléthorique et j'imagine
davantage donc mon rôle comme
facilitateur du dialogue de l'échange à
la fois entre les territoires et et le
niveau national et à la fois entre le
Parlement et le gouvernement moi
j'imagine enfin je me suis toujours
positionné dans ce
dans cette démarche de dialogue
d'échanges et je vous j'imagine la
présidence d'eldafitte davantage comme
ça donc je pense que mon statut a eu
local au regard de ce qu'est la fuite
c'est-à-dire 5 personnes et plutôt un
avantage parce que je vis aussi c'est
contradictions parfois sur le terrain en
particulier dans les hauts de France et
je peux mesurer aussi
les besoins de mobilité aujourd'hui de
nos populations et parfois les
difficultés souvent les difficultés face
auxquelles aujourd'hui ils font face
donc j'ai le sentiment que mon mon rôle
de mère ou mon rôle de président de
communauté urbaine est plutôt un
avantage pour essayer de de répondre à
ce rôle de facilitateur du dialogue et
au moins d'être ancré sur des réalités
de terrain donc voilà un petit peu
comment j'imagine les choses
j'ai déjà bien entendu prévu de dégager
si vous me confirmez à ce poste de
président les moyens en temps qui me
permettent de le faire j'avais d'autres
responsabilités nationales à France
ville durable la Fédération nationale
des agences d'urbanisme c'est des choses
bien entendu que je peux que je peux
arrêter pour consacrer tout ce temps
aujourd'hui à la fit en tout cas j'ai
déjà essayé d'imaginer ce que pourrait
être un agenda et mobiliser le temps qui
est nécessaire je suis à mon deuxième
mandat à Dunkerque à la communauté
urbaine souvent le premier mandat est
particulièrement prenant le deuxième
mandat c'est aussi l'occasion de
s'ouvrir un peu l'esprit et je trouve
que essayer de de mettre à profit mon
expérience de c'est presque maintenant
huit ans 9 ans dès le local au profit de
d'échanges à l'échelle nationale ça peut
être une plus-value en tout cas moi ça
me motive et je tenais à vous l'indiquer
voilà j'espère ne pas avoir été trop
long dans ce préliminaire et puis bien
entendu je suis à votre disposition
merci pour ce proposliminaire et début
de réponse je vais donner la parole à
mes collègues et je venais la parole à
Madame filleul
ah merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
de me donner la parole je souhaitais
répondre à la question de Monsieur Belin
qui demandait si monsieur vergrid vous
étiez le candidat idéal pour prendre la
tête de cette structure je voulais dire
que de mon point de vue vous en avez
toutes les caractéristiques tant du
point de vue de la formation
universitaire de votre parcours
professionnel mais également de votre
pas d'histoire d'amour entre Patrice et
moi-même
que de votre parcours d'élus où vous
êtes distingué particulièrement sur la
question de la gratuité dans les
transports publics néanmoins cela ne
m'empêche pas monsieur vergrid de vous
interroger sur deux questions qui me
tiennent particulièrement à cœur qui
sont particulièrement importantes pour
le nord et également pour les hauts de
France la question du fluvial
quel est votre vision du fluvial ce
fluvial qui est toujours la part du
pauvre on va dire dans le budget de la
fit qui est toujours la part du pauvre
on va dire et également dans les projets
nationaux et pourtant nous avons en
France le plus grand réseau de France de
fluvial le plus
sous-utilisé en Europe et celui pourtant
qui est à la marge de développement la
plus importante et la plus économe en
énergie en énergie en
gaz à effet de serre donc je voulais
savoir si vous aviez l'intention de
bousculer ces équilibres traditionnels
au sein de la fuite et également vous
interrogez mais je suis sûre que mon
collègue de la Somme va le faire
également vous interrogez sur votre
vision du canal senor et du
développement économique qui peut être à
l'origine du canal Sana moi j'ai déjà
posé la question des plateformes
quadrimodale moi je pense qu'on rate une
occasion de l'histoire de n'avoir que
deux plateformes
quadrilles modales prévues dans
l'échéancier du canal senor par exemple
deuxième question pour ne pas être trop
longue la question du fer dans la région
des Hauts-de-France les présidents de la
République se succèdent les présidents
de région se succèdent les présidents de
la SNCF se succèdent et on est toujours
dans le même marasme par rapport au fer
et au bon service public
ferroviaire dans la région des Hauts de
France est-ce que là aussi vous avez une
vision par rapport à cette situation
mais
merci la parole est à Joël Bigot
merci monsieur le président
Monsieur le Maire moi je ne vous connais
pas donc
je vais vous poser des questions du
néophyte on est ravi de vous entendre
parce qu'on a entendu déjà quelques
candidats à ce poste récemment donc on
va voir si vous vous différenciez si
vous êtes rightmen in the right place en
tout cas
on va voir si votre nomination pose
moins de difficultés que d'autres
nominations que nous avons eu examiner
ces temps-ci moi je souhaiterais pour ma
part vous interroger sur les vous avez
parlé des dépenses et de la vision que
vous auriez à ce poste moi je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur les
mobilités douces ou actives qui sont de
votre ressort la fuite France finance en
effet par le biais d'appel à projets des
continuités cyclables sur certains
programmes territoriaux c'est l'un des
points essentiels de la décarbonation
qu'on doit mettre en place en février
dernier la fuite participait justement
un colloque européen sur la question en
part travailler avec l'université
Gustave Eiffel en substance tous les
intervenants s'entendaient sur le
nécessaire report modal vers une
mobilité active pour les trajets du
quotidien ceux qui sont à moins de 5 km
en général dopé notamment par les vélos
à assistance électrique en terme
d'aménagement
Lafitte va-t-elle promouvoir les
constructions nouvelles sachant que ça
n'est pas toujours facile il y a des
contraintes urbanistiques le plus facile
c'est
des créations de de nouvelles
infrastructures des autoroutes à vélo
notamment qui sont
étudiés et qui sont réalisés afin
d'éviter les coupures physiques qui
rendent l'usage de la bicyclette
dangereux et ça c'est extrêmement
important si on veut réussir cette
transition écologique sous votre
président est-ce que vous allez
faciliter l'expansion de ces modes de
déplacement les Esserts à nos
engagements bas carbone je m'en tiendrai
là pour ceux qui me concerne merci
Monsieur le Maire et candidat
la parole l'état Jacques clinique puis
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Maire votre mandat va effectivement
commencer par un rendez-vous essentiel
en le disait avec la remise du rapport
du du coi gouvernement alors c'est pas
la fuite qui décide c'est pas elle qui
détermine les choix de programmation
mais l'agence on l'a dit n'est pas pour
autant un simple tiroir-caisse une
exécutante vous avez parlé d'un rôle
plutôt de conseil de surveillance de
facilitateur du dialogue vous allez
d'ailleurs
si votre nomination est effective être
pleinement membre du Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures on
sait même si comme vous nous n'avons
bien sûr pas lu ce rapport à venir que
le COI s'apprête à proposer un scénario
dit de planification écologique au
volume nettement plus important que la
simple poursuite de la trajectoire
d'investissement en cours parce que
celle-ci n'est manifestement pas en
mesure de répondre aux enjeux de
transition énergétique et écologique de
nos transports
[Musique]
je vais donner la parole à Frédéric
marchand puis après je vous proposerai
de répondre avant de reprendre une
deuxième série de questions merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le Maire
bonjour
vous avez dans votre propos liminaire
insistez sur la relation étroite qui
existe entre mobilité et aménagement du
territoire et vous savez combien je
partage ce point de vue à ce sujet Bruno
Belin évoqué lui aussi dans son
intervention la question des RER
métropolitains sujet qui a été remis sur
la table par le Président de la
République à la fin du de l'année
dernière et avec votre vision
d'aménageur j'aurais aimé vous entendre
puisque je pense qu'on souhaite
effectivement au collectivement dépasser
la simple logique de la caisse de
financement mais sans doute faire en
sorte qu'à la fuite devienne un
partenaire incontournable vous l'avez là
aussi rappelé votre vision s'agissant
des projections qui ont été faites et
des projets qui ont été annoncés pour
vous pour qui effectivement
l'aménagement du territoire et la
question des mobilités sont
indissociablement liées merci beaucoup
merci pour cette série les quatre
questions je vous propose de d'y
répondre
merci
merci pour
pour ce qui est ce qui a été dit je
reviens sur sur quelques points je vais
je sais pas si je vais réussir à les
prendre dans l'ordre mais quelques
points
sur sur la question du fluvaille du
fluvial pardon qui est finalement
[Musique]
connexe à celle du rail en réalité il
est évident que demain ça doit devenir
une priorité comme le rail puisque
l'enjeu est quand même de déplacer toute
une partie notamment du fret mais
également pour les déplacements
voyageurs de la route vers le fluvial et
vers le fer donc évidemment ça doit
devenir un enjeu majeur pour la fuite et
pour les enjeux de mobilité dans ce pays
pour les années qui viennent j'en
profite d'ailleurs en parlant de la
route pour dire que l'autre enjeu c'est
de réussir aussi à mobiliser les camions
sur les grands axes de de circulation de
notre pays et pas forcément sur les
routes nationales mais en tout cas le
but du jeu une fois qu'on a réussi à
faire ça c'est c'est de les limiter et
de réussir à mettre ses transports là
notamment le transport de marchandises
j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus sur sur le
fluvial et et le
d'où la nécessaire le nécessaire
développement du fluvial dans les années
qui viennent alors il y a déjà des
engagements qui ont été pris le contrat
entre l'État et VNF montrent une
trajectoire qui est à la hausse le canal
sonore aujourd'hui c'est un engagement
ça correspond à un niveau d'engagement
de Lafitte aujourd'hui c'est acté donc
il y a des choses là-dessus qui vont
dans le sens que vous indiquez et bien
entendu pour la suite j'ai envie de dire
c'est le débat après le rapport du C8
qui nous permettra de voir si
aujourd'hui les ambitions qui ont été
fixées notamment si le contrat
d'objectif entre entre les entre l'État
et VNF et suffisant ou pas mais en tout
cas aujourd'hui on peut voir que la
tendance est à la hausse et c'est un
sens qui me paraît évident et que ça
doit constituer une priorité au même
titre que le rail le rail vous l'avez
évoqué vous avez évoqué la situation des
des Hauts de France
qui est aujourd'hui dramatique à mon
avis assez comparable à celle de
l'Île-de-France aujourd'hui je on va pas
mettre un classement de un ou deux on va
dire que les deux sont dramatiques
aujourd'hui on est un niveau de service
ferroviaire qui qui atteint je trouve la
limite de la du désengagement de la
population vers vers le fer dire
aujourd'hui moi je vois dans les hauts
de France mais ça doit être pareil en
Île-de-France des gens qui
arrêtent de prendre le train pour
revenir à la voiture exactement à
l'inverse de ce qu'on souhaite en terme
de décarbonation des mobilités donc
effectivement il y a un enjeu immense
là-dessus le problème est aujourd'hui
double dans les hauts de France puisque
ce conjugue un problème d'infrastructure
à un problème de recrutement de
personnel qui a atteint un niveau
absolument incroyable donc je pense que
du côté de la SNCF qu'il y a des choses
à faire également en termes de
management et en termes de
d'attractivité pour les métiers liés
liés aux rails demain aujourd'hui quand
même en termes de recrutement c'est
c'est devenu extrêmement difficile et
puis il faudra se poser la question des
infrastructures on atteint aujourd'hui
la saturation d'un certain de sillons et
donc du coup il va bien falloir investir
il y a déjà des des engagements qui ont
été pris ne serait-ce que dans le budget
2023 les 100 millions supplémentaires
qui ont été mis sur la régénération je
pense que ça va dans le bon sens encore
une fois là aussi je renvoie vers le
débat qu'on aura à l'issue du rapport du
coi parce que c'est finalement là que
les choses vont se décider pour pour les
années qui viennent et effectivement
c'est pas la fuite mais ça a été dit qui
est en situation de décisionnaire j'ai
envie de dire vous aurez sans doute une
responsabilité plus importante que que
le plus résident de la ville quel qu'il
soit sur les mobilités douces
l'engagement de la fille était
historique puisqu'on est passé si je me
trompe pas de 350 millions sur 7 ans
investi sur les mobilités douces avec
une rallonge du plan de relance qui
devait être je crois 245 millions a
aujourd'hui un engagement pour 2023 de
250 millions mais sur une seule année
sur 2023 donc on a multiplié par 5
l'engagement de la fuite en 2023 sur la
question des mobilités douces donc que
je pense que ça va dans le bon sens là
on est sur un report modal pour le
transport urbain ce report modal il doit
se faire sur le transport collectif et
les mobilités douces et donc je pense
que ça va dans le bon sens de la
décarbonation des mobilités sur la
question des mobilités douces pour moi
il y a deux éléments essentiels que j'ai
pu vivre en tant que président de la
cote urbaine de Dunkerque il y a d'abord
le développement des infrastructures
vous l'avez dit je pense qu'il faut
accompagner le développement de
nouvelles infrastructures qui donnent un
sentiment de sécurité vous l'avez évoqué
au cyclistes aujourd'hui ce qui n'est
pas toujours le cas dans dans ce qui
peut être peut être fait aujourd'hui
donc si on n'arrive pas à développer les
infrastructures on n'arrivera pas à
développer les mobilités douces mais il
y a aussi un autre choix et qui relève à
mon avis davantage la différenciation
territoriale qui est le choix du modèle
qui est associé
moi j'ai constaté aujourd'hui pour
essayer de faciliter les mobilités
douces en termes de service il y avait à
peu près deux modèles il y a le modèle
de l'économie de la fonctionnalité c'est
à dire le vélo en libre-service qui se
développe par exemple sur un certain
nombre de métropole c'est plutôt
efficace mais qui ne convient pas
forcément à des villes moyennes ou à des
petites villes ce modèle par exemple du
vélo en libre-service et de l'économie
de la fonctionnalité n'était par exemple
pas adapté à ma ville de Dunkerque et
donc on est parti sur un modèle nous de
propriété de sécurisation et donc la
nécessité de faire des parkings pour
sécuriser effectivement et l'aide à
l'acquisition de vélo et je pense que
c'est là qu'il faut être très
pragmatique et laisser aux collectivités
locales
l'identification du modèle qui est le
plus adapté à leur territoire à certains
endroits on aura du vélo en
libre-service à d'autres endroits il
faudra privilégier la réalisation
d'infrastructures de sécurisation des
parkings à vélo et laisser les
collectivités en aide à l'acquisition en
transport moi j'ai choisi le deuxième
modèle j'ai abandonné par exemple le
vélo en libre-service et ça marche
formidablement bien parce que le modèle
est adapté à ce qui est le territoire et
ne pas partir c'est un peu vrai pour le
transport collectif vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure ne va partir sur une
vision préétablie et c'est en sac pour
l'expérience des lieux locales elle peut
être utile je pense que il faut que il
faut laisser aux collectivités locales
ce choix la stratégie qui est fait pour
développer les mobilités aussi il n'y a
pas de il y a pas de recette adaptées
partout en toute circonstance et en tout
lieu et donc cette question des
infrastructures elle doit se doubler du
choix d'un modèle qui doit à mon avis
être fait au niveau local néanmoins pour
je reviens puisque votre sujet était sur
la fuite la fille d'aujourd'hui donc
engage un montant qui n'avait jamais été
atteint sur les mobilités douces
ensuite vous avez évoqué monsieur le
sénateur le j'ai envie de dire le
rapport du CV moi je l'ai pas lu
[Rires]
à vous écouter
à vous écouter à vous écouter vos
affaires beaucoup plus que moi
et votre dernière question est dur à
quelle infrastructure renoncée
je vous avais évoqué la
décarbonation des mobilités évidemment
tout ce qui concera la décarbonation des
mobilités doit être des priorités demain
mais je voudrais pas par exemple que un
sujet comme l'aménagement du territoire
soit relégué derrière les décarbonations
de mobilité à titre personnel je
m'exprime ma petite personne le débat il
aura lieu collectivement mais comme vous
m'avez interrogé a-t-il personnel
pourquoi je vais d'ailleurs ça fait
aussi écho à la question des RER
métropolitains et ma vision des RER
métropolitains
aujourd'hui si on veut que notre pays
aille dans le sens du développement
durable donc al dans le sens de la
décarbonation
continuez l'hypermétropolisation et ce
beaucoup d'experts l'ont évoqué est une
erreur c'est à dire les hypermétropoles
ne vont pas dans le sens du
développement durable ce qui va dans est
très souvent en France ville durable on
l'évoque et on le rappelle ceux qui peut
aller dans le sens du développement
durable c'est un réseau de ville maillé
je sais pas si vous vous rappelez de la
fin des années 90 ce débat animé par la
data sur le polycentrisme maillet cette
question du polycentrisme magnet est
tout à fait compatible à mon avis avec
le sens de la ville durable et du
développement durable parce que l'idée
de mailler effectivement ville moyenne
petite ville métropole peut avoir une
efficacité plus importante en matière
d'adaptation au changement climatique et
de lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique paradoxalement
et donc je pense que bien entendu il
faut choisir la décarbonation des
mobilités c'est-à-dire le report modal
de la route vers le fluvial et le rail
pour le pour les transports urbains vers
le vélo vers les transports collectifs
mais je pense qu'il faut aussi intégrer
l'aménagement du territoire comme une
réponse à la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique et l'organisation spatiale de
notre pays est aussi un enjeu de lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique et donc
à chaque fois peser sur les
infrastructures ce que peut être la
contribution à l'enjeu de lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique mais une
échelle large et donc c'est pour ça que
je
la réponse est difficile à votre
question parce que une infrastructure
qui peut permettre une petite ligne par
exemple une petite ligne de train qui
peut permettre de mieux desservir une
ville moyenne qui aura peut-être pas un
aussi grand impact d'un rebord modal des
camions de la route vers le fluvial elle
peut avoir finalement à la fin un impact
tout aussi intéressant on va dire de
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
voilà
et donc voilà pourquoi je pense que il y
a pas de réponse toute faite à votre
question si ce n'est un examen au cas
par cas en fait des infrastructures et
de leur contribution globale à la vision
qu'on se fait de l'avenir du pays et la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
donc je sais pas si j'ai répondu à votre
question mais ce que je vais simplement
dire c'est que je n'ai pas une vision
manichéenne du choix lutte contre
dérèglement climatique ou pas je pense
par exemple qu'une petite ligne entre
une ville moyenne et une petite ligne
par d'autres une petite ville et une
ville moyenne peut avoir une
contribution tout aussi importante à la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique à
condition de l'analyser finement et en
profondeur et elle se situe pas
forcément au même horizon et donc ça
répond aussi à cette question des RER
métropolitains parce que finalement il
pourrait y avoir deux visions du RER
métropolitain c'est relié sa métropole
et la banlieue pour aller vite ou
réussir un maillage à un échec à une
échelle régionale entre la métropole les
villes moyennes et les petites villes
je pense que l'une l'un des points clés
de la réussite des RER métropolitain ce
sera le deuxième scénario si les RER
métropolitains c'est relié la banlieue
au cœur d'une métropole je pense que
c'est un échec à moyen et long terme je
pense que si les RER métropolitain c'est
penser à un réseau maillet de ville
moyenne et de petites villes autour
d'une métropole je pense que ça a un
avenir effectivement je pense que ça
peut être plus efficace inhiné à la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
et donc voilà un petit peu ma vision
personnelle des RER métropolitains et ça
je pourrais l'illustrer à travers
plusieurs régions qui me semblent qui me
semblent correspondre à ce que je viens
d'évoquer
j'espère avoir répondu à peu près à tout
voilà
merci je vais donner la parole à
Stéphane de me
merci monsieur le Président
bonjour chers collègues des Hauts de
France moi je voudrais rebondir sur les
propos de Martin filleul qui elle-même
avait rebondi sur les propos de Bruno
Belin j'étais député de l'Est de la
Somme pendant longtemps et donc je suis
très impliqué sur le dossier du canal
senor Europe qui est comme vous le savez
la plus grosse infrastructure prévue par
l'Union et pour l'Union européenne donc
de ces de ce siècle probablement
les relations sont excellentes entre la
fit et la société de projet vous avez
d'ailleurs voté votre budget en nous
confirmant 53 millions d'euros et on
vous en remercie et donc je souhaite
simplement vous poser la question de
savoir si vous continuerez à être un
partenaire fidèle efficace et solide
avant de me prononcer sur votre
nomination
Philippe Tabarro
merci monsieur le Président après le
passage éclair mais efficace de Jean
Castex à la tête de Lafitte avec une
augmentation sensible du nombre de
conventions signées nous revoilà devant
un nouveau candidat à la tête de la
danse l'excellent rapporteur Belin
presque tout dit en tant
qu'administrateur de la fit après grâce
à Didier mandeli je connais le problème
de l'incertitude des recettes
contribution du secteur aérien en d'Ancy
les sociétés autoroutières qui
maintenant ne veulent plus payer
et puis
on perçoit le produit des amendes de
police une fois que tout le monde s'est
servi et s'il en reste
je connais à l'inverse les besoins
immenses qui seront confirmés par le COI
voilà parce que
c'est pas un scoop mais avec ma collègue
Christina erzog et mon collègue Michel
Dagbert nous avons beaucoup travaillé
sur ce sujet même entre noël et jour de
l'an et donc nous n'allons pas révéler
un scoop aujourd'hui mais tout
simplement que ce rapport du coi
montrera combien dans notre pays nous
avons besoin de lignes ferroviaires nous
avons besoin de route nous avons besoin
de BHNS nous avons besoin de piste
cyclables
alors je vais en venir à mes deux
questions vous avez un emploi douter les
compétences techniques pour ce poste ou
les collègues qui vous connaissent me le
confirment et vous nous le montrez mais
avez-vous avez-vous l'influence
nécessaire ou les garanties pour
sécuriser des recettes suffisantes pour
attraper le retard que connaît notre
pays en matière de d'infrastructures de
transport et puis ma deuxième question
va peut-être vous surprendre car elle va
être très direct j'ai cru comprendre que
sur l'échiquier politique avant de vous
rapprocher de la macronie vous étiez un
homme de gauche
c'est pas grave
il peut laisser moi
il peut y avoir des gens de gauche
compétents
notamment en matière de transport
j'en veux pour preuve certains collègues
ici présente cette commission ainsi que
le regretter ancien président de la RTB
Bernard
plus sérieusement je sais que vous êtes
ou que vous avez été vous nous l'avez
dit président de d'autorité
organisatrice vous avez donc la
connaissance et l'expérience pour ce
poste par contre d'une ao qui pratique
la gratuité dans les transports publics
certes une idée très généreuse mais qui
me pose un problème car pour moi rien
n'est gratuit au moment où se pose plus
que jamais avec acuité la question du
financement des modalités de financement
du transport je pense que cela ne sert
pas la cause des transports je ne vais
pas développer mais c'est une conviction
profonde pour moi
alors allez vous faire du prosélytisme
pour vanter du prosélytisme pour vanter
les avantages supposés de la gratuité de
votre ao ou vous cantonnez à une
impartialité ou une neutralité sur cette
épine au sujet par rapport à votre
probable futur fonction
merci je vais donner la parole à
Jean-Pierre corviset
et
il est parti
et à Guillaume chevrolier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Maire candidat vous avez développé les
motivations votre candidature pour pour
la fuite effectivement la fuite qui est
au cœur d'enjeux important autour du
financement des infrastructures de la
mobilité dans le contexte du changement
climatique
vous avez indiqué que la fuite c'était
la garantie du temps long
je vous rejoins là dessus il fait
effectivement il faut présidence qui
s'installe dans la durée pour
pour plus d'efficacité parce qu'il faut
aussi du temps pour pour l'action sur
des sujets comme les infrastructures sur
nos transports routier ferroviaire et
fluvial et puis il faut aussi du temps
pour se permettre d'assurer un vrai
suivi dans la dans la consommation des
crédits de cette agence donc cela
suppose un engagement réel dans le temps
et donc quel l'engagement vous êtes prêt
à entendre vous êtes prêt à consacrer
pour pour cette agence et puis
compte tenu de la jurisprudence Castex
ou il nous avait fait part de ses
motivations importantes mais on lui a
proposé mieux il est parti et c'est bien
légitime donc vous est-ce que si on vous
propose mieux dans les quelques mois
est-ce que vous vous partirez également
où est-ce que comme vous l'avez exprimé
compte tenu des motivations très fortes
que vous avez pour la fuite vous
resterez parce que les enjeux sont
importants c'est la première question et
la seconde la loi 3DS a permis le
transfert de de route nationale au
département
pour une vingtaine de collectivités dont
mon département et on s'en réjouit on a
récupéré enfin on va récupérer une
partie de la route nationale 162 comment
la fuite s'est préparée à ces transferts
enfin comment vous envisagez cela et
quel accompagnement pour pour l'après
parce que c'est ces routes sont sont des
routes structurantes et on aura besoin
de
d'un accompagnement pour pour
l'aménagement du territoire dans ces
départements merci
la parole est à Nicole Bonnefoy
Président Monsieur le Maire bonjour
nous sommes tous attachés à la question
de la décarbonation des transports avec
le report modal que nous appelons tous
de nos vœux le transport des
marchandises c'est aujourd'hui est
aujourd'hui capté à 89% par la route
alors que la moyenne européenne et de
75% nous savons tous que ce type de
transport est l'un des plus polluants et
pèse lourdement sur nos émissions à gaz
à effet de serre quand on sait que le
report des marchandises sur le
ferroviaire bien évidemment permettrait
de diviser par 9 nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre donc il est
urgent de consacrer nos investissements
à ces aménagements d'ailleurs
Jean-Pierre pharedoux c'est également
prononcé en ce sens c'est grâce à notre
ténacité que la ligne de fret des
primeurs Perpignan Gennevilliers a été
maintenu et a permis d'éviter la
circulation de 9000 camions sur les
routes donc cette réussite doit bien
évidemment en appeler d'autres dans mon
département la par exemple nous avons
une garde fret à Cognac qui a vu 180
millions d'euros d'investissements
publics et qui pourtant aujourd'hui ne
fonctionne pas elle est inutilisée alors
qu'elle pourrait être une opportunité
pour les entreprises de Cognac en
particulier pour réduire leurs
empreintes carbone donc lutter contre la
surdensité du trafic poids lourd sur nos
routes pour permettre d'atteindre un
double objectif
environnemental celui de la transition
écologique bas carbone et celui des
nuisances provoquée par ce type de
trafic donc quel est votre ambition dans
ce domaine sachant que la hausse des
coûts du transport du fait de la crise
énergétique pourrait remettre en cause
les quelques progrès enregistrés dans le
secteur du fret ces dernières années
merci pour votre réponse
Monsieur le Maire je vous proposerai
répondre à mes collègues merci
sur le canal senor Europe voilà je pense
que c'est acté et je vous avais
évidemment le soutien de le soutien de
la fit voilà j'espère avoir répondu
simplement mais je pense que c'est ce
que vous souhaitez
je vais prendre dans le dans le désordre
je vais je vais répondre à la question
de oui je suis de gauche
je vais mais j'ai pas de carte voilà
j'ai aucune carte dans aucun parti
politique aujourd'hui j'ai eu par le
passé mais voilà
j'ai simplement donné mon avis
effectivement au moment de la dernière
présidentielle sur ce qui me paraissait
le plus important pour le pays voilà sur
la question la gratuité des transports
je vais répondre de manière double je ne
serai pas neutre sur ce qu'il fallait à
Dunkerque
tout à l'heure j'ai parlé de
différenciation territoriale je pense
qu'il faut être hyper pragmatique en
matière de mobilité c'est le pragmatisme
qui doit dominer et justement d'avoir
aucune idéologie mais sur rien
il y a il y a des territoires qui ont un
problème d'offre de transport c'est par
exemple le cas de l'Île-de-France
si vous faites la gratuité des
transports dans une agglomération qui a
un problème d'offre c'est une
catastrophe
une catastrophe parce que vous produisez
un surcroît de demande dans un manque
d'offres vous aggravez le problème et
vous diminuez le financement
si sur un territoire comme Dunkerque
où il y a un problème de demande il y a
une offre mais les gens ne montent pas
dedans
pour plein de raisons Dunkerque a été
une ville rasée pendant la guerre elle
était reconstruite pour la voiture une
culture de la voiture
et donc il fallait trouver le moyen
de redonner le sens du transport
collectif dans une ville qui l'ignorait
moi-même ne pensais même pas aux
transports collectif pour le dépasser
c'était même pas une option dans ma tête
voilà je voiture où est-ce que je passe
je me gare
et un moment donné on y a réfléchi et on
s'est dit c'est cet outil là et je
considère la gratuité comme un outil
parmi tant d'autres
et ça a fonctionné à Dunkerque plus 110%
de fréquentation en semaine en 4 ans
plus de 100 à 300 % de fréquentation le
weekend
c'est plébiscités aujourd'hui ça donne
un réseau qui a une capacité mobilité on
accueille aujourd'hui des entreprises on
va modifier le réseau pour pouvoir
générer des déplacements de domicile
travail donc à votre question est-ce que
ce que c'est est-ce que je serai neutre
sur est-ce que c'était la solution pour
Dunkerque non je continue de penser et
la population aussi aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs il y a uneanimité à Dunkerque
pour dire que c'était la bonne réponse
dans la situation dunkerquoise
est-ce que c'est la bonne réponse à
Biarritz Toulouse Toulon etc je n'en
sais rien je n'en sais rien probablement
pas probablement pas et comme je le
disais tout à l'heure quand je parlais
du vélo je parlais des modèles entre les
modèles économiques de la fonctionnalité
économie de la propriété je ne sais pas
ce qui est le mieux par exemple en terme
de report sur les mobilités douces dans
tel ou tel agglomération et je pense que
c'est là qu'il faut faire confiance aux
élus locaux les élus locaux ont une
connaissance de leur territoire et ils
savent peut-être trouver la solution qui
est adaptée donc est-ce que je ferai du
prosélytisme pour la gratuité des
transports non parce que je pense que
dans un certain nombre de territoires
c'est une mauvaise solution voire même
une très mauvaise solution qui a
graverait les problèmes est-ce que je
ferai du prosélytisme pour dire que à
Dunkerque c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
oui je continue de penser et beaucoup de
gens avec moi continuent de penser qu'un
dunker c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
je pense que en fait en matière de
transport faut tuer toute idéologie
toute idéologie dans n'importe quel sens
en fait en réalité pareil si tout à
l'heure je parlais du vélo l'économie de
la fonctionnalité c'est aussi à la mode
le vélo en libre-service c'était aussi à
la mode bah moi Dunkerque ça marche pas
voilà et je continue de penser qu'à
certains endroits ça marchera pas même
si ça à la mode donc je pense qu'il faut
se méfier terriblement des modes en
matière de mobilité le pays a été
beaucoup de collectivités ont été
victimes de la mode en matière de
mobilité je pourrais faire la liste des
mods je l'ai vécu quand j'étais
directeur d'agence d'urbanisme et je
pense qu'en matière de mobilité rien ne
vaut une bonne analyse finalement de ce
qu'il faut faire localement et c'est en
ça que le dialogue avec les élus locaux
me semble pertinents parce que ils
connaissent parfaitement leur territoire
et avec une analyse fouillée on arrive à
trouver le bon outil donc voilà pour
répondre à la question donc je ne suis
pas un idéologue de la gratuité des
transports c'est tout le contraire je
suis plutôt à l'inverse quelqu'un
d'hyper pragmatique mais qui ne veut
écarter aucune solution
ce que je pense que je pense que notre
notre débat sur les mobilités en France
s'ouvre trop parfois d'idéologie par
rapport à d'autres pays et je pense
qu'il au contraire privilégions le
pragmatisme et regardons la solution la
plus adaptée à tel ou tel territoire
et ensuite vous avez la question des
déplacements longs parce que là je parle
des déplacements urbains quand on parle
de la gratuité des transports je parle
des transports urbains à l'intérieur de
l'agglomération de la guerre coin j'ai
jamais évoqué la gratuité des transports
à des échelles régionaux par régional
pardon ou national ça n'a rien à voir et
puis le le fruit des mobilités n'est pas
le même la question du lien social n'est
pas le même donc vous voyez je pense
qu'il faut aborder chaque question de
manière assez pragmatique et trouver les
bonnes solutions qui est adaptée voilà
mon positionnement par rapport à ça donc
ni écarté ni prosélytisme qu'est-ce qui
est adapté au bon territoire et je pense
que c'est la meilleure façon de d'y
répondre
et c'est pas une question de générosité
la gratuité c'est une question
d'efficacité pour moi
je la vois pas comme un sujet généreux
c'était ce qu'il fallait faire c'est 4
millions et demi la gratuité sur un
budget de 500 millions de la
collectivité je pense que si j'avais
investi ces 4 millions et demi ailleurs
je pense que j'aurais été moins efficace
voilà c'est vraiment une question
d'efficacité
la question de l'incertitude des
recettes elle est
évidemment au coeur vous vous l'avez
très bien dit vous avez évoqué la
question de la contribution des
volontaires des sociétés d'autoroute qui
doit arriver là à un contentieux on aura
le on aura la réponse prochainement en
attendant la fuite n'a pas va vous étiez
administration de la fuite n'a pas n'a
pas intégré ce chiffre pour 2023 on
verra le ce que donnera le contentieux
néanmoins vous avez raison sur le fond
il y a aujourd'hui des recettes
incertaines face à des dépenses qui
elles sont certaine la formule n'est pas
de moi d'ailleurs mais mais mais mais
vous connaissez très bien ce débat et
donc du coup vous posez deux questions
derrière
l'une qui renvoie au débat qu'on va
avoir dans les six mois c'est à dire où
est-ce qu'on va quel est le bon niveau
de dépense et quelle recette on va aller
chercher aujourd'hui
il y a des recettes qui peuvent être
mobilisées au local mais est-ce que ça
suffira est-ce qu'il faudra aussi aller
chercher d'autres sets à l'échelle
nationale je pense que c'est le sens du
débat qu'on doit avoir dans les 6 mois
qui viennent et puis la deuxième
question que vous posez elle est plus
personnelle ce que j'ai l'insuffisance
suffisante alors si je me compare à Jean
castech je vous répondrai non je suis ni
un ancien Premier ministre ni même un
ancien ministre voilà
néanmoins pour ceux qui me connaissent
je quand je dis que je défendrai une
cause je la défends bien donc vous
pouvez compter sur moi pour essayer de
peser
[Musique]
sur ce débat
aussi
quand je crois en quelque chose j'ai
tendance à y mettre les moyens et je
crois comme vous c'est pas que le
rapport du coi parce que je me doute de
ce qu'il y aura dedans je crois que
notre pays est vraiment arrivé à un
moment où il faut vraiment investir
beaucoup sur ces infrastructures je
pense qu'on a trop tardé on a manqué de
on collectivement notre pays on a manqué
d'anticipation on a manqué de
prospective je pense sur ces sur ces
questions là hors domaine
parfois avec mon langage un peu direct
je dis la France a peut-être manqué
d'aménagement du territoire depuis 30
ans la France a peut-être manqué de
vision sur sur les politiques de
mobilité depuis 30 ans et donc
aujourd'hui on paye le prix d'un
sous-investissement sur cette question
là et donc oui j'ai tendance à penser
que notre pays on a largement besoin
donc je m'en ferai le défenseur avec mes
moyens je veux pas dire mes petits bras
en tout cas l'influence que je peux
essayer d'avoir et en tout cas je
défendrai le besoin de mobilité une
population tant je vois que c'est une
souffrance aussi du quotidien et tant
que je vois aussi à quel point
aujourd'hui avec la montée du prix de
l'énergie ça peut être un facteur de
fracture territoriale profond et
dangereux pour notre pays donc je pense
qu'il faut il faudra y mettre les moyens
et je me battrai je pense à vos côtés
d'ailleurs parce que je pense que vous
en êtes convaincu aussi est-ce que je
m'installe dans la durée
oui j'ai envie de dire je je
pour l'instant j'ai pas encore fait un
jour donc puisque vous m'avez pas validé
donc
si si vous me faisait confiance j'ai
bien l'intention de de d'y mettre les
moyens d'y consacrer les moyens
Haddock tout à l'heure je parlais de
fonctions que je pourrais lâcher pour
essayer de m'adapter tout à l'heure je
parlais d'un deuxième mandat qui me
donne du temps aujourd'hui pour
m'inscrire dans ce débat national donc
oui j'ai mis à l'intention d'y passer du
temps très clairement en plus c'est un
sujet qui me passionne donc forcément on
a envie de passer du temps dans les
sujets qui qui nous passionnent si votre
question était est-ce que je le fais
pour une ambition autre PDG de la RATP
non je pense que je ne serai pas PDG de
la RATP ou une fonction autre c'est pas
dans c'est pas dans ma tête aujourd'hui
je prends la fille telle que telle
qu'elle est c'est-à-dire une un bon
moyen pour moi de devenir sur un débat
national qui me passionne vraiment et
aujourd'hui je
je suis très intéressé par cette
question et j'ai envie d'y prendre toute
ma part et je trouve que les six mois
qui viennent c'est vraiment une belle
occasion pour justement pouvoir avoir
une place dans ce débat là à vos côtés
d'ailleurs puisque vous aurez aussi une
place centrale dans ce débat donc moi
j'ai envie j'ai envie d'y passer du
temps d'y consacrer du temps et d'y
rester tant que tant que ce sera
possible et si vous me confirmez
sur la question des transferts vous avez
évoqué la question des transferts ça
relève davantage du programme 203 mais
il va de soi évidemment que la fille qui
consacrera aussi des moyens et enfin la
question du du report des des camions
sur la route et le fluvial j'ai dit je
partage complètement ce que ce que vous
avez dit donc j'ai envie de dire j'ai
rien à ajouter par rapport à tout ce que
vous avez évoqué je trouve que c'est un
enjeu essentiel pour pour d'autres pays
évidemment une priorité donc donc voilà
je je ne peux que confirmer ce que ce
que vous avez dit
bien il reste quatre boîtes de parole
sauf que il y en a un qui est parti donc
ça fait plus que trois et j'ai de la
parole à Angel Préville merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Maire alors moi
je vais reprendre des choses qui ont
déjà été évoquées mais en essayant de
d'y aller un petit peu plus en
profondeur notamment sur le sujet de
l'anticipation sur les infrastructures
et puisque tout va très vite et qu'il
nous faut accompagner les changements
des habitudes de mobilité notamment
parce que vous l'avez dit entre le coût
des carburants la nécessité de baisser
les gaz à effet de serre vous me voyez
venir il faudra accorder de plus en plus
importantes à disons créer les toutes
les possibilités à nos concitoyens
d'utiliser plus les mobilités douces
donc vélo mais également le cheminements
piétonniers or mais vous le savez très
bien tout a été fait pour la voiture
notamment puisque je voudrais évoquer un
sujet on a parlé mon collègue Joël Bigot
en a parlé tout à l'heure je voulais
revenir sur les financements qui sont
prévus jusqu'à présent 250 millions
d'euros
en comparaison je vous donne par exemple
les premiers investissements à
Haute-Garonne pour créer des pistes
cyclables 50 millions d'euros donc je
pense qu'il va y avoir dans l'avenir à
prévoir d'y mettre beaucoup plus
d'argent et parce qu'on a deux problèmes
on a le problème de sécurité et donc
continuer à faire des pistes cyclables
qui sont juste une bande blanche au bord
d'une route en disant ben là vous pouvez
voilà circuler à vélo et donc il y a
quand même un problème de sécurité
routière premier problème deuxième
problème ma collègue l'a évoqué problème
de santé publique quand vous êtes juste
à côté des camions et des voitures vous
êtes là vous faites du sport en plus
donc vous respirez à plein et donc voilà
le alors tout le monde l'a pas mesuré et
heureusement que il y a plein de
concitoyens qui commencent à faire du
vélo mais là quand même on a un problème
et peut-être qu'il va nous falloir faire
des infrastructures comme ça existent
vous êtes du Nord probablement vous
savez ce qui existe dans les Hauts
Pays-Bas par exemple avec des routes
complètement séparées qui permettent de
de relier des
et qui permettent même de relier des
villes sur des trajets de très longs en
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres ce que
nous n'avons pas du tout dans notre pays
donc comment vous voyez le développement
possible le choc de l'offre qui nous
faudrait faire parce qu'on a déjà plein
de concitoyens qui commencent à utiliser
les vélos mais il va nous falloir
prévoir que ce développement devra être
plus important et parce qu'au niveau du
porte-monnaie au niveau de la santé ça
va être bien meilleur et je terminerai
par là puisque on a un problème
également dans les agglomérations les
métropoles une étude sortie il y a pas
longtemps indiqué que chez les jeunes
pour 80% la seule activité sportive
qu'ils font c'est l'activité qu'il faut
en classe
or il nous faudra permettre sans doute
que les jeunes puissent à nouveau comme
on le faisait je pense que quand on
était enfant
allait à pied ou à vélo ou à bicyclette
dans leur établissement scolaire ce qui
est on va le dire ou entre oui alors moi
je privilégier alors trottinette mais
pas électrique du coup pour faire une
activité sportive et parce que on avait
ça avant on l'a plus on sait bien que
les jeunes ils sont de plus en plus
devant leurs petits écrans donc voilà il
y a un enjeu aussi à envisager
complètement voilà merci
la parole est à Christine
Monsieur le Maire bonjour en complément
de mon excellent collègue Philippe
Tabaro du coi donc moi je tenais à vous
poser une question concernant le TGV
est-ce que vous serez un futur président
tout est TGV ou bien vous penserez aux
lignes secondaires ferroviaire
moi je suis un département de la Moselle
donc j'ai énormément de demandes parce
qu'on parle beaucoup de TGV donc ça que
les horaires TGV tout va bien on est
bien desservi mais concernant donc les
lignes secondaires on est très attendu à
ce niveau là parce que des travailleurs
ont besoin
de prendre le train pour rejoindre aussi
des TGV et moi je je crois aussi j'étais
un petit peu rassurée par vos propos
parce que moi je je suis aussi j'étais
mère je suis aussi à tenace quand j'ai
je suis sur un projet moi je crois
beaucoup à la mobilité rurale parce
qu'on parle beaucoup de mobilité au
niveau
urbain mais la mobilité rurale j'y crois
parce que c'est quelque chose aussi qui
qui sauverait les petites communes parce
que je reparle de la Moselle parce que
la Moselle c'est très urbain mais aussi
aussi très rural et comme ma collègue
l'a dit c'est vrai quand on était plus
jeune on avait des transports en commun
on avait des bus on avait des trains il
y avait de la mobilité et aujourd'hui on
l'a plus on se retrouve avec des
personnes âgées qui n'ont pas le permis
et on sait aujourd'hui qu'il y a des
jeunes qui ne passent plus le permis
pour des raisons financières et un achat
de véhicule même électrique dans le
futur c'est très cher donc il reste dans
les villes ils viennent pas dans les
communes dans les petits villages voilà
donc je voudrais savoir aussi si vous
êtes aussi un futur président pour la
mobilité rurale merci
la parole est à Laurence Müller braunet
Jean-Pierre est revenu il prendra la
parole en dernier voilà Jean-Pierre
tu n'as pas parce que j'étais un t'étais
inscrit bon ben c'est bien
merci Laurence
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
Monsieur le Maire alors moi je ne vous
connais pas je suis du département du
Bas-Rhin mais je voulais attirer votre
attention sur deux problématiques vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure les réseaux
Express métropolitains qui semblent être
un dispositif d'avenir or il se veut que
nous sommes deux sénateurs du Bas-Rhin
dans cette commission et nous venons de
vivre vraiment en réalité la mise en
fonction du Réseau Express métropolitain
de de Strasbourg de l'agglomération
strasbourgeoise et c'est pas très
convaincant on en a fait beaucoup
beaucoup de communication positive hors
réellement cette devait permettre de
faire circuler jusqu'à 120 trains en
plus chaque jour au départ ou à
destination de Strasbourg et c'est
complètement l'inverse alors moi je suis
élue locale d'un canton qui est limité à
cette nouvelle ZF en plus qui qui est
instauré et là les communes ont
participé au financement de gare en
milieu rurale et entre 7 et 8 heures le
matin il y avait cinq trains qui
s'arrêtaient aujourd'hui il y en a plus
qu'un depuis le 11 décembre donc c'est
une c'est la panique totale bien sûr les
maires sont mécontents puisqu'ils ont
financé en partie Sega les trains de
s'arrêtent plus on est en ZF en face et
la totale et cette image de réseau
express métropolitain formidable là
vraiment je vous invite à venir sur
place alors je me suis entretenu la
semaine dernière avec la présidente de
l'euro métropole de Strasbourg et avec
le conseiller régional en charge des
transports ferroviaires et des TER
notamment sur le grand est la raison
invoquée alors j'imagine quel intéresse
tout le monde c'est le manque de
ressources humaines voilà donc on peut
on peut lancer des réseaux Express
métropolitain promettent 120 trains
supplémentaires par jour si on n'a pas
le personnel en fait la conséquence elle
est complètement négative donc ça
c'était vous alerter pour un sujet
peut-être qui serait qui serait
intéressant de de vous en saisir si vous
êtes élu et ensuite concernant le plan
vélo donc moi je suis vice-présidente de
l'Association Vélo et territoire qui
fait partie du groupe Alliance et qui
suit donc le plan vélo qui a été annoncé
par la première ministre le 20 septembre
dernier doté de 250 millions d'euros
donc pour 2023 et 2 milliards et demi
normalement sur le quinquennat or le
premier comité interministériel qui qui
devait avoir lieu le 2 décembre dernier
alors est-ce que c'est parce que il y a
voilà il y a un changement de présidence
au niveau de la fuite je ne sais pas
mais il a été reporté on a dit un
problème d'agenda de la première
ministre mais la problématique est la
suivante c'est que les collectivités
locales que ce soit régional les
intercommunalités surtout et aussi les
départements et bien s'engage de plus en
plus fortement dans des politiques vélo
ambitieuses et elles portent l'essentiel
des dépenses d'investissement et de
fonctionnement et 80% des
investissements sont prévus dans la
deuxième partie de mandat on est
maintenant bientôt en mars 2023 la
deuxième partie de mandat municipale va
s'engager et leurs attentes face à
l'étape planificateur sont immenses car
ce comité interministériel c'est lui qui
doit en fait donner le feu vert au
travail de l'État et les le lancement
des appels à projets aujourd'hui tout
est suspendu donc il y a vraiment une
urgence de ce côté-là pour que toutes
ces annonces elles soient concrètement
possible aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
démarrer sur les projets en fait sur le
terrain
250 millions d'euros et 2 milliards et
demi ça peut paraître beaucoup mais là
je rejoins ma collègue Angèle prévu qui
vient de s'exprimer il y a quand même
une étude qui a été faite et la France
est 21e en en termes d'investissement
nationaux par habitant et par an je
rappelle que c'est 1,20 en France c'est
4 fois moins qu'en Italie cette plus de
7,7 fois moins qu'en Allemagne et 11,3
fois moins que dans les Pays-Bas
puisqu'ils avaient et 30 fois moins
qu'en Irlande donc ce sont des chiffres
qui paraissent importants mais il y a
voilà ils sont encore pas niveau pour un
pays comme la France et surtout il y a
urgence pour débloquer tous les projets
locaux des communes des
intercommunalités des départements qui
sont dans les tiroirs merci
pouvez-vous me dire si ce sont des
sujets que vous prendrez à bras le corps
Monsieur le Maire je vous propose de
répondre et puis pour qu'on puisse clore
vers 11h pour vous laisser repartir à
l'Assemblée nationale
alors sur d'abord la question Aline
secondaire versus tout TGV je pense que
vous avez compris ma vision du monde je
pense que ce qui manque aujourd'hui à
notre pays c'est une vision du réseau du
réseau de ville justement et je pense
qu'on a peut-être trop réfléchi autour
de l'attractivité des métropoles et pas
assez dans une logique de réseau et de
maillage en fait pour moi je pense que
l'essentiel est là je vis juste à côté
de la Belgique est un exemple typique du
maillage territorial et je pense qu'on
aurait bien fait de s'en inspirer même
si d'ailleurs au niveau de la Belgique
ça recule un peu d'ailleurs mais cette
idée du maillage territorial la question
n'est pas de savoir si seulement si on
relie bien à Bordeaux à Paris la
question est de savoir comment on maille
l'ensemble du territoire national
et d'où aussi la question de la multi
modalité qui est peu abordée je vais
vous raconter mon expérience aujourd'hui
de Dunkerquois on est en train de
discuter avec la communauté de communes
juste à côté communauté de communes
rurales pour savoir comment on va
réussir à articuler la ruralité à notre
réseau de transport public qui
maintenant très performant et très
attractif et le coeur du sujet c'est
comment on réussit à faire de la
multimodalité c'est-à-dire comment faire
accepter à la population qu'elle va
commencer avec un mode qui dans une
ville moyenne est une hérésie quand on
commence par un mode on finit par le
même mode et essayer de faire évoluer la
représentation pour essayer d'aborder la
question de la multimodalité et donc
cette question du maillage et la façon
dont on arrive à penser la multi
modalité entre les différentes niveaux
de territoire ruraux petite ville
moyenne si pour moi la question
essentielle et je trouve d'ailleurs que
le budget 2023 de la figue l'illustre
assez bien puisqu'il y a un équilibre
plutôt bon entre justement ce qui relève
des grands changer TGV etc et ce qui
relève la régénération du réseau ce qui
notamment du rail ce qui relève
effectivement de la modernisation donc
je trouve que c'est un bon équilibre à
respecter évidemment pour des questions
d'équité territoriale à l'échelle
nationale on peut difficilement dire par
exemple au sud-ouest aujourd'hui bah
écoutez vous aurez pas et vous
regarderez les TGV dans le Nord ou dans
l'est donc c'est il y a une question
d'équité territoriale à l'échelle
nationale qu'on peut comprendre voilà
mais je pense que comme vous l'avez dit
la question aujourd'hui c'est comment on
maille ensemble voilà et donc cette
question d'aligner secondaire elle est
pour moi aujourd'hui centrale et c'est
ce qui nous permettra justement de
décarboner nos mobilités
voilà donc je voulais vraiment je
voulais vraiment vous confirmer cette
vision des choses qui qui est la mienne
à laquelle je crois vraiment beaucoup et
que et que je vis même en territoire et
quand on parlait des RER métropolitains
tout ailleurs pareil c'est ce que j'ai
évoqué c'est cette question du maillage
la question
du maillage territorial qui est qui est
central la question du vélo
je viens juste d’ailleurs d'un il y a
quelques mois d'un déplacement au
Danemark pour tout vous dire j'ai eu
l'occasion de de voir le snake
à Copenhague et autres parce que
effectivement à Dunkerque on a souhaité
après le plan transport collectif du
mandat précédent développer un plan vélo
pour ce mandati on a quelques résultats
on a progressé de 42% sur la première
année au niveau de notre plan vélo donc
voilà à titre personnel j'y crois le
comité interministériel de ce que je
sais il est il est vraiment correspond
vraiment à un report non voilà et je
pense que c'est pas lié à à la dignation
de la présidence de la fille qu'il est
vraiment prévu au premier trimestre on
me l'a confirmé
les engagements vous l'avez vu ils sont
trop c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure on parle de 50 millions par an à
250 millions par an c'est quand même un
signe maintenant le débat qu'on doit
avoir à la suite du rapport du coi
j'imagine qu'il va pointer aussi la
question du vélo encore une fois j'ai
pas lu le rapport du civisme mais
j'imagine que la question du vélo va
être quand même poser et de l'ambition
qu'on veut se donner donc on pourra
réouvrir dans les six mois qui viennent
l'ambition d'accompagnement je pense
sincèrement aussi et ce que j'ai vu au
Danemark le montre bien que ça part
aussi d'une volonté politique locale il
n'y a pas il y a voilà alors il y a
l'accompagnement financier il y a aussi
la volonté politique locale faut se le
dire faut se le dire franchement voilà
là on a on a on a mis en place un plan
vélo et on voit on voit la puissance de
feu qu'on peut avoir à partir du moment
où on met où on met des moyens sur cette
question là et je partage complètement
votre diagnostic sur les bandes
cyclables à la place des pistes
cyclables évidemment nous on se bat
effectivement pour limiter au maximum
les bandes cyclables ce n'est ni secure
ni bon pour la santé je partage
complètement et donc du coup il faut des
moyens il faut pouvoir dégager dégager
des moyens pour réaménager nos voiries
voilà donc là dessus la fuite moi je
serai je serai ravi qu'elle puisse
encourager davantage il y a aujourd'hui
des appels à projets qui sont mis en
oeil il peut y avoir 30%
d'accompagnement etc tout ce qui ira
dans ce sens là évidemment aura mon
soutien parce que je pense que avec le
transport collectif c'est quand même le
meilleur moyen d'avoir du report modal
pour les déplacements du quotidien
intra-urbain j'ai envie de dire c'est
clair à une échelle plus large sur la
ruralité aujourd'hui ça sera sans doute
plus difficile il faudra quelques années
pour atteindre la culture danoise ou la
culture d'autre pays mais en tout cas si
on y met les moyens on peut on peut
arriver à faire évoluer les choses
ce que vous avez évoqué sur Strasbourg
bienvenue au club je savais pas que
l'Alsace était où le grand est comme les
hauts de France ou l'Île-de-France donc
bienvenue au club des problèmes RH
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on a sur les
hauts de France je sais plus on a
le pourcentage des trains qui qui ne
sont plus qui ont été supprimés faute de
personnel personnel conducteur
personnellement personnelle contrôle
aujourd'hui je pense alors c'est pas du
ressort de la fille du tout puisque là
pour le coup je suis simplement
spectateur de cette situation il est
urgent de poser la question du
recrutement et de l'attractivité des
métiers à la SNCF mais j'ai envie de
dire c'est pas à moi malheureusement à
répondre à cette question et après comme
je l'ai dit il y a cette question du
personnel il y a une deuxième question
qui elle concerne davantage lafit c'est
qu'il y a quand même un problème
d'infrastructure on l'a vu avec la
saturation d'un certain nombre de
sillons je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
cas en grand est sur Strasbourg je pense
que pour le coup vous avez vraiment
évoqué la question du recrutement mais
je vous propose devenir effectivement en
plus ça me fera plaisir de voir des des
personnes que je connais bien et donc je
vous propose de venir à Strasbourg que
vous m'y avait invité je veux bien
répondre favorablement justement pour
voir s'il y a si c'est un problème de
recrutement uniquement ou si comme en
haut de France ou comment Ile de France
c'est un problème de recrutement mais
aussi un problème d'infrastructure voilà
donc voilà voilà bon ben
j'aurai l'occasion de
on va peut-être pas lancer
alsacien Strasbourg et
[Musique]
on va on va libérer
le candidat pour qu'il puisse se rendre
à l'Assemblée nationale pour la même
prestation
et puis nous allons procéder au vote le
rapporteur va vous appeler
individuellement pour venir voter on va
vous distribuer les bulletins